- On ne sait pas quand ou même
si les travailleurs seront
de retour sur les chantiers
des Habitations Trigone.
C'est une véritable douche
froide pour Anne Bouliane,
qui est locataire dans
un immeuble de Mascouche dont
la construction n'est pas encore
terminée.
ANNE BOULIANE, locataire
- Vraiment pas drôle, parce que
nous, quand on est arrivés ici,
on pensait que tout serait fini,
mais ils avaient déjà perdu leur
licence, ils avaient déjà été
arrêtés.
- Vices de construction,
structre opaque semant
la confusion chez ses clients.
La régie du bâtiment a révoqué
les 19 licences des Habitations
Trigone en septembre dernier.
L'entreprise les a ensuite
récupérées le temps de porter
sa cause en appel. Un appel
qu'elle vient de perdre devant
le Tribunal.
Ses chantiers sont donc arrêtés
de nouveau.
- Au priye, on aurait
aimé ça que ça soit fini.
- Selon la Régie du bâtiment,
une dizaine de projets en cours
sont touchés, mais on ignore
combien d'unités exactement.
Il pourrait y en avoir
des centaines ou même plus.
Pour le moment, les clients
sont dans l'incertitude la plus
totale. Ils devront vérifier
leurs contrats pour voir
quelles sont leurs protections.
SYLVAIN LAMOTHE, porte-parole,
Régie du bâtiment du Québec
- La RBQ ne détient pas
ces informations-là. Quelle est
la nature du contrat et tous
les détails, est-ce que
le bâtiment est couvert par
un plan de garantie.
- Le nouveau plan de Garantie
de construction résidentielle
s'appliquera à trois tripl
en construction à Laval et qui
n'ont pas encore été livrés.
Les clients auront deux
possibilités :
FRANÇOIS-WILLIAM SIMARD, vp,
comm., Garantie constru. rés.
- C'est vraiment
le remboursement des
jusqu'à un maximium de 50 000 $.
C'est important de le préciser
parce qu'il y a un maximum
effectivement prévu par
la réglementation. Et il y a
le parachèvement des travaux
jusqu'à un maximum effectivement
de 200 ou 300 000 $ selon le ca.
- Mais on ne sait pas si
Habitations Trigone a souscrit
à des plans de garantie pour
ses immeubles de plus de quatre
étages, estestestestestest
facultatif.
En vertu d'une loi entrée
en vigueur en janvier 2020,
les dépôts des acheteurs doivent
être remboursés en totalité.
Ce sera en quelque sorte
un premier test pour
cette nouvelle disposition.
MARC-ANDRÉ HARNOIS, dg, Asso.
consommateurs qualité constru.
- On n'a aucun moyir àir àir àià
quel point ça a été respecté par
les promoteurs et est-ce qu'en
pratique, ça va fonctionner.
- Et pour les immeubles en
construction, la suite
des choses pourrai
compliquée.
- Va falloir voir comment
Trigone va gérer ça. Parce
que si elle a plus le droit
de construire, logiquement,
il va falle fasse
construire par quelqu'un
d'autre, voire qu'elle vende
ses participations dans
les différents projets
à d'autres entrepreneurs.
ble de savoir si
Habitations Trigone ira en appel
pour récupérer ses licences.
L'entreprise n'a pas donné suite
à nos demandes d'entrevue. Ici d
Radio-Canada, Mas